[Applaudissements]
ne vous oublierai jamais
[Musique]
tout ça bien tous ensemble on est bien
sur la tête de ma mère mamie on dirait
qu'elle est au concert de booba je lis
et je vais le faire appel
ouais mais version rock ah ouais c'était
quoi mais oui a battu bafé tu fais moins
chargé il va y aller à pied vers moi
allez je vais aller je mets deux places
la l2 c'est pour moi et je paye un jeu
fait pas payer celle là c'est ça aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t
[Musique]
d
mais ce sourire
je
[Applaudissements]
7le alors avec le tout les deux sets de
ce que vous faites là
allez-y
oui on dirait qu'elle est en train
d'essayer de 10 et quelques uns à
garrett eu c'est vrai ça c'est dangereux
j'occupe eu de l'écho vu que la business
class et isabelle tu es magnifique et
franchement je te le dis et bravo même
pour la tenue et où je tape d'un couac
issia c'est super de faire l'émission si
ça m'a nommé super aujourd'hui tu peux
le faire avant tu pouvais pas